it's obvious that the mainstream media
is working hard to minimize the hunter
biden criminal probe
but before the election they wouldn't
touch the story at all
but somehow the new york times back in
february thought
hunter biden's new career as an artist
was a story
and congratulations are in order to
hunter biden
as vanity fair is reporting that the
federal investigation into his taxes
isn't stopping him from getting a solo
art show
at a prestigious new york city gallery
next year
so joining us now with more is the new
york post columnist
and fox news contributor miranda devine
and fox news contributor tammy bruce
thank you both for being here tammy i
want to start
with you because hunter biden had time
for an interview with the new york times
about his art career
hasn't had time to answer senator
johnson's questions and respond to a
senate
inquiry and the new york times doesn't
seem to have space in its paper or
online
to do a single story about eric swalwell
and what's going on
so what's your take on this mess and the
lack of coverage from the new york times
and the other liberal media well uh
thank you
jason great to see you and matt had some
great points about the media but we're
all seeing now i think the degree of
how it really is affecting national
security right it's not just an irritant
or that we'd rather have certain
different kinds of stories
the fact is courtesy of the internet fox
news
other elements that are invested in fair
imbalance reporting
is that we really now do know what's
going on
and we're able to judge what it is we're
not being told
that's been the key throughout all these
years and this is what the media now
apparently does very well
it's lying by omission so as opposed to
an entity in our republic that is
supposed to
hold the powerful to account they now
have thrown their lot
in not with even all the powerful but
with a particular party with a
particular agenda
and now their mission is not informing
us but in manipulating us
in fact in brainwashing us to some
degree in moving along
a a certain kind of message whether it
is by omission
uh by not telling you about let's say
that the chinese connection with hunter
biden in that family
or it is an elevating someone up to try
to cast them into different light like a
a story about his art show
but it really moves into an abandonment
of a job that they have to do
which is directly linked into the
security of this country
to the legitimacy of the government and
there's a point where it will
all collapse because now that we know
what's happened
and they are going along merrily along
as though nothing can stop them
but there has got to be a point where
this conversation gets to be very
serious
because it is about election
interference and it's about national
security
especially when you're dealing with
foreign interference and money going to
politicians
that kind of dynamic so we've got a
we've got a huge no matter who's in the
white house for the next four years the
next eight years next
12 etc is we've got a big job to do to
deal with what the media has become
and how dangerous it is to our internal
work and to external work
you know i miranda i served eight and a
half years in the united states congress
i think if i had to list out the three
or four biggest disappointments right
near the top of that last
top of that list would be the lack of
intellectual curiosity
and fairness with the media to report
legitimate stories
and report them without a bias that is
so obvious at this point
now miranda you're with the the new york
post you were publishing some of the
greatest their best work
most in-depth investigative stuff before
the election
only to have it suppressed so when you
look now at december 18th and you look
at the issue
how do you see it how do you explain it
to the people in nebraska and iowa and
louisiana what's going on here
hi jason well it's a very clear case
of suppression by the media and
it was actively first of all ignored
and then censored the new york post we
got the
hunter biden laptop we published our
first stories
on october 14 which was three weeks
before the election
ample time for there to be a proper
forensic
analysis of it all in the media and
unfortunately the very day that we
published
we had the other media ignoring it and
then we had big
tech censoring it twitter actually
closed down our account for two weeks
telling us that we had
broken their hat materials rules when
we hadn't at all and in fact they
admitted afterwards that no there was
nothing about
hacked material in what we did but you
saw
this evolution of the media first of all
ignoring the story
poo pooing it and then you had 50
former intelligence operatives such as
john brennan and james clapper
notorious for their pushing of the
russia collusion lie
they signed a letter saying that our
story and the laptop from hunter biden
that he had so recklessly
abandoned at a delaware mac repair shop
was russian disinformation they admitted
they'd never
actually looked at the laptop they
hadn't any evidence to say that it was
russian disinformation
but that's what they said and that was
the story that was run by
new york times and cnn and washington
post and all the rest of the
sort of establishment media that the
rest of the media looks to to set the
narrative
and it was only after the election when
hunter biden thought that it was safe
enough to come out
and issue a press release uh curiously
under the banner of his father's biden
harris
transition team uh admitting that hunter
was under federal
investigation what he called uh
so-called tax
issues and since then we've found that
there are as many as four
separate investigations in washington
and delaware into various
aspects of hunter biden's overseas
business dealings
including potential money laundering so
this is a big issue
it's not just pushed away and talking
about it as tax issues and it's not just
hunter biden it's actually about joe
biden
and joe biden's involvement in his
family's
influence peddling schemes overseas
whether it be ukraine
russia kazakhstan or most importantly
for america's national security
china what did joe biden know and how
intimately involved was he in that
business
we see quite a bit yeah and it's uh
it is telling that hunter biden has
something to say and then it comes out
on from the campaign letterhead that i
think that uh
is just another clue of how dep how in
depth and how wide this is
because i do think it involves the
entire family and as sean hannity said
it ain't going away miranda tammy thank
you so much for joining us tonight